welcome back president biden speaking
more today on the u.s withdrawal from
afghanistan and of course he took the
time to blame his predecessor
united states will do our part
and we are already working closely with
refugee organizations to rebuild a
system that was purposely destroyed by
my predecessor
scintillating and a former navy seal
posting this blunt message for biden on
taking ownership and on what the
president should be telling americans
about afghanistan
i made some critical errors
namely
i underestimated the strength of the
taliban americans and our allies are all
stranded
and that is my fault
but they will not be stranded for long
we will conduct rapid strike rescue
missions until we have recovered and
evacuated all our citizens allies and
friends
any person that interferes with these
operations will be killed
you know uh the break jesse you were
saying that you think you could take him
uh i don't
know i don't know about that i've said a
lot of things in the break greg never
that
that was inspiring though i mean do you
honestly believe that a president would
ever say something never because the
politicians don't politicians could
never give their political opponents
that kind of ammo right and admit that
they were wrong and joe biden's been in
dc his whole life so he is playing the
long game he sees this thing as listen
november is around the corner then it's
going to be winter people are going to
be thinking about covid i'm going to
steal myself i'm not gonna get emotional
i'm gonna go out there and i'm gonna
read the teleprompter and i'm almost
gonna psychologically convince myself
that it's not as bad as it seems and he
thinks he can get through this i don't
think he can get through this there's a
huge disconnect right now between the
people and the president and he's lost
it he's lost control of events and
everybody can see that now you set a
deadline at the 31st and then he says oh
you know we might have to move the
deadline so he sends the cia director to
kabul to meet with the taliban to
negotiate extending the deadline taliban
says screw off
we're not going to extend the deadline
if you extend the deadline we'll start
firing rounds and by the way from now on
we're not going to let any more afghans
reach the airport
joe biden says okay
we're going to keep to the deadline
he's boxed himself in
yeah there are no good options now and
that's his calculation he's trying to
avoid a mogadishu we just heard jennifer
artfully explain that but that's not the
point even adam schiff left a briefing
and said there's no way we can get
everybody out by the deadline there's
thousands that are still going to be
trapped and political reports said
americans are routinely denied access to
the airport by the taliban it's a
catastrophe yeah so jessica this is
truly a cluster rhymes with truck
however however
i want to steal man joe biden to you and
you tell me if there's an answer to this
everyone seems to have the right answer
to this problem except for the
administration even the average cab
driver goes
he got this backwards like you don't
have the troops leave first you don't
abandon the most important air base
everybody knows this
so did they already entertain these
options and decide this is the steel man
part of it that this would be the least
worst option that it could actually be
it could actually be worse than this and
they just figured rip the band-aid off
and get everybody out and that'll i mean
i'm just trying to figure out why they
chose this path
i hope that's what happened and we have
seen a number of people from the obama
administration even carries over to the
biden administration who have said that
they're really unhappy with what's going
on you have veterans on both sides of
the aisle i mean if you watch like seth
moulton for instance did an interview
where he's apoplectic about what's going
on and the work that he and the people
he commanded put in to end up in this
place now
i'm obviously haven't been in any of
these rooms but i maybe this is the
least bad option
or someone said that but we do know that
that wasn't what the intelligence
community said that wasn't what people
in the military were saying so there has
to be some inner circle that is
operating kind of separated from the
next layer of the circle and that is
concerning
and there's something to jesse's point
about what's going to go on and
elections are always the thing that
matters here i think a lot of presidents
and lab administrations make
calculations about foreign policy things
where they say this will blow it's not
here
right
and the way that you can judge whether
that's true is if your cab driver knows
about it if the person who
is checking out a grocery store normal
people
and everybody knows about what's going
on right here and they're asking
questions and they're wondering did it
have to be this way they're not
wondering should we leave
they're wondering did it have to be this
way and that's the kind of thing that
can
stick to you over time it's as though
dagon he snatched defeat from the jaws
of victory even i mean it wouldn't be we
could have left and redefined the
mission which is you know which is what
what jennifer was talking about which is
what makes total sense
uh just like the border yeah biden broke
something that was fixed right i started
talking about this on day one we went
from america first to america last to
america over
that this is a president who leads with
shame
not strength he has talked over and over
about the system you know systemically
racist ugly poisons of the racism in the
united states and we turn around what do
we do we kowtow and geneflect
and
bow down to country after country that
hates us
we rejoined the paris climate accord why
did that benefit americans no but we're
ashamed of all the fossil fuels that we
use we try you know tried to reopen
negotiations about the iran nuclear deal
at the same time that you're taking a
hammer to the our energy independence
here you and then we've had we've sat
back and allowed countries like china
to vomit the woke left-wing pablum of
the media and these liberals back in our
face tony blinken met with um in alaska
in march with a china chinese
official and they were he was lecturing
america about our sins and then tony
blinken the secretary of state then
approaches the u.n about having the
human rights council lecture us on
systemic racism that's what we are they
are ashamed of america rather than being
proud rather than in jocko
willing's words may god bless america
and may god have mercy on the souls of
our enemy because we will not
joe biden is on the run
because he's he's ashamed you know the i
i wonder dana did uh to general milly's
you know a take on white rage is that
going to help him deal with the taliban
it is not i don't think so i can answer
i can answer that one general keene said
something um on air about a week ago he
said that
his entire career
president biden has been relentlessly
stubborn
and so that's one of the reasons why he
would never say
what uh jocko was suggesting but there
is one precedent of something that it
was a very hard thing
to do and to
bring to the american people and is
extremely unpopular and eventually it
worked and that was when president bush
did the surge i mean that talk about
unpopular to say like oh actually um
we've had problems we've made mistakes
and we need to send more troops in
and not even even the cabinet was like
oh no we're well no we're not and it
took several uh months well weeks uh to
a couple of months for president bush
and general petraeus to convince uh the
national security council that this was
the right thing to do eventually it ends
up that it was the right thing to do so
there there is a way to do this and the
other thing is i do think americans
understand
risk
and they can handle risk they can handle
the truth so if there were to be
something like what draco suggests which
is we're going in there and we're going
to get our people if you say
there might be
some casualties and we're going to do
everything we can to make sure that
doesn't happen i just want to be i want
to want to prepare you for what could
happen
americans can accept that uh but i think
what they can't accept is this and i
think you see it in the numbers the usa
today poll that came out today's suffolk
poll has the president at 41
approval total only 32 percent of
independents approve of the job he's
doing that number has dropped like by 30
points yeah just the past few months and
i think that um that it's only tuesday i
imagine he'll be in the 30s by the
weekend oh yeah there you go glad they
buried that laptop story eh hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else